good morning john february was uh for
me personally for the world at large a
little rough
but also it was good a lot of people
started getting vaccines including a lot
of people that i
know and love and care about a mean
petulant victimhood based presidency was
being quickly maybe a little too quickly
forgotten which
has been a relief and then unrelated to
any of that except
that it persevered through it the
perseverance rover
landed safely and spectacularly on the
surface of mars and like other cool
stuff is happening too like spacex is
learning how to land a new rocket
you know slowly and mrna therapies are
proving to be potentially useful
beyond just this vaccine into a lot of
different things that will
improve human health and life and as
disastrous as this year has been for
education
it has started to feel a little bit like
a wake-up call that we don't
need it to increase in cost dramatically
every single year
that there might be other ways to do
this without raising the barriers as
high as they will go
it's possible that we're not going to
learn anything from any of this
but my mood is elevated it is good and
this may have something to do with the
fact that like
going into this winter everyone in
montana who i knew was like this is
going to be very bad
and then once we were in it it was but
no one said anything we just head down
went through it yes it sucks outside and
we can't go anywhere else inside
except for our own homes safely so we
will just do it and not mention it and
now it is nice outside we have plenty of
winter left don't get me wrong but
spring
is definitely coming and we're
definitely on the other side i'm
starting to feel like what i'm
experiencing isn't just hope
it's joy i see spring and i know that
it's coming
and i'm not just talking about the
weather a piece of me
and a lot of like the world outside of
me as well
is kind of encouraging me not to feel
this feeling some of that is definitely
wise like we don't know what the future
holds we should not let our guard down
there may yet be twists and turns in
this thing but some of it
is a little bit self-indulgent it's like
my brain's saying but it could have gone
so much better
but we didn't have to have it be this
bad if only these people had done x if
only the government had done well and
like yes
absolutely brain you are correct it
didn't have to be this bad but look
i kind of don't want to think about the
winter during the spring
learn from it yes whine about it i don't
think so like i don't know who i
serve by being mad at people who don't
care that i am mad at them who don't
know that i'm mad at them i'm trying to
let go of that but then the last reason
my mind is discouraging me from feeling
good
is just the reality of the injustice of
this disaster
of future disasters of the world in
general even absent pandemics or climate
change or whatever
i worry and i wonder about the
selfishness of
the emotions that i'm feeling so i've
been thinking about what to do with that
and here's where i'm at right now i
don't know if it's where i'll be at
tomorrow i think instead of asking
myself what emotion is appropriate right
now which seems like a labyrinth that i
can enter and then never leave i'm gonna
try to ask
what am i feeling why am i feeling it
and is this an emotion that's gonna
inspire uh depression or complacence
or like better action
in the world positive impact on myself
my family
and the rest of everybody else and if i
feel like the feeling is going to
improve things
for me and for the world i'm not going
to ask myself to stop feeling it even if
it's a nice feeling and i'll tell you
it's nice to feel nice feelings that's
where i'm at right now anyway
john i'll see you on tuesday